For this procedure you're asked to reverse a list, and any elements that are lists
within that list you're also asked to reverse.
I'm going to label the elements A, B, C, and each of these elements needs to be in reverse order.
C, B, A.
Now C is itself a list, which means that C is going to have to be reversed as well.
B is a list, and A is just a single element.
Well, when it's a single element, that's it. We're done. A is fine.
B we're going to have to reverse.
Each element in B is now just an element. It's not a list. That's fine.
Finally, in C it looks like we've got a lot of work to do here,
because we've got 4 and this list of lists.
Those need to be reversed.
Four is okay, but 5, 6, 7--that's another list of lists.
That one needs to be reversed, and so on.
We're going to have to keep going until we get down to looking at the elements themselves which are not lists.
That gives us the structure for our procedure,
because we're doing the same thing over and over again to smaller parts of the lists,
that really lends itself well to using recursion, and that's what we're going to do.
No we're going to define the procedure deep_reverse.
The first thing we're going to check is whether we have a list as our input.
We're going use this function is_list,
and if p is a list, then what we are going to do is create a new list, an empty list.
We want to go through the elements in the original list in reverse order.
In order to do that, we're going to count backwards.
The last position is the length of the list -1.
Then we want to go length of list -2, -3, and so on, all the way down to 0.
We can do that using range.
For i in range the length of the list -1.
Because range stops one before the second input number,
we have to go to -1 because we want to end at 0.
We also want to tell it to count backwards.
We want to count in -1 steps.
What do we want to do? Well, we just want to append each element of the list in reverse order.
But we don't want to just put the element in,
because remember we've actually go to reverse each element as well.
We're going to call the procedure again on each of the elements of the list.
Then when the loop has finished, we're just going to return the result.
Now, we haven't got a stopping condition yet.
When did we stop when we were doing the example?
We stopped when we got to an element that was not a list.
So our else condition we just return whatever that element is.
That's our base case for the recursion.